Katy Perry reveals she's 100% ready to  move on from her feud with Taylor Swift  and ranks her past lovers from best to  worst in bed  [Laughter]  [Music]  the 32 year old swish-swish singer has  been getting extremely candid during her  big brother style YouTube livestream to  promote her new album witness and on  Sunday when James Corden made an  appearance to play a little game of  spill your guts or filler guts things  definitely got personal now but this is  working on the notion that they're all  good no run John Mayer Diplo and Orlando  Bloom or eat a thousand-year-old egg  Katy chose to spill Diplo yes  and then mayor then bloom bloom then man  oh I was saying all three are  exceptional  the day before Katy opened up about her  ongoing drama with Taylor Swift  revealing to Arianna Huffington quote  I'm ready to let it go  absolutely 100% I forgive her and I'm  sorry for anything I ever did I really  want the best for every person  [Music]  you